[Musik]
kognitive
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 in
der letzten folge seit ihr geisteskrank
in den kommentaren abgegangen alle
meinten ich soll hier reingehen in das
portal ihr wollt die hölle sehen und das
werden wir heute auch machen zuvor muss
ich mich allerdings ganz kurz ein
bisschen darauf vorbereiten
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe mich
jetzt grad mal ein bisschen vorbereitet
auf die hölle das gold baut sich nicht
mitnehmen allerdings habe ich mir zum
beispiel noch einmal mitgenommen
bisschen mehr holz ich habe auf meinen
bogen verzaubert das vornehmlich und in
die kommentare geschrieben dass ich das
machen soll und nun
[Musik]
ist der moment gekommen
ich würde sagen wir warten gar nicht
mehr lange
sondern springen rein und bewegen uns
zum ersten mal in diesem projekt
minecraft mit luca staffel 2 in die
hölle
[Musik]
also einen beschissenen ort für das
portal jetzt wirklich nicht geben können
da ich jetzt die mitten auf dem lover
see geboren bin würde ich sagen sprint
noch mal ganz schnell eben zurück und
holen uns ein bisschen cobblestone und
ich werde zudem eine diamant spitzhacke
einfach mal hier lassen die werde ich
denke ich nicht brauchen weil ich ja
genügend eisen und holz mit habe mir
auch so noch weitere eisen spitzhacken
machen zu können die sache ist
allerdings
[Musik]
dass ich hier irgendwie rüberkommen muss
ich glaube der schnellste weg zum
festland ist hier vorne lang deswegen
nehme ich mir jetzt einfach mal meine
bruchsteine und bau mich hier so ein
bisschen rüber über 1 2 mw und generell
baue ich unser portal auch mal so ein
bisschen sicherer 1 sowie das ganze
jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal so ein
bisschen besser aus und
was alles
und es dann
das ist direkt eine festung
oh mein gott leute okay ich will am
liebsten mich war ganz ganz fix in
sicherheit bringen und mal eben kurz auf
die andere seite laufen ich habe keine
ahnung was das für komische skulpturen
[Musik]
was elvis wieder untergetaucht ich habe
keine ahnung ob der jetzt immer näher
kommt aber ich will einfach nur hier weg
ich will einfach nur überaus fest ich
habe keine ahnung wo sie auftaucht ich
habe ein bisschen schiss auch ehrlich
gesagt ich will einfach nur hier vorne
etwas schön
wenn er hier auftauchte aber direkt
zurück in meine welt
ich habe auch nicht das buch mit wo ich
gucken kann wer das ist nun ob der böse
oder nicht aber
ich denke er hätte mich eigentlich schon
längst angreifen können oder na gut
freunde wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
durch wir müssen uns jetzt einfach mal
sputen und hier einfach nur rüberkommt
es ist nicht weiter sind vielleicht 20
blöcke oder so und da sind wir jetzt
auch schon hier vorne auf dem festland
angekommen ist hat auf jeden fall
geklappt freunde das ist unser weg dass
dahinter ist unser portal ihr könnt ihr
auch gerne in die kommentare schreiben
was ihr eventuell dort feiern würde was
ich dort hin bauen damit das portal ein
bisschen schöner aussieht weil irgendwie
sind wir in der ziemlich beschissenen
gegend gespannt
ich will wissen was das für ein tier war
hier vorne ist es wieder
das sieht aus wie sonnen noch nen es
ungeheuer
aber irgendwie
[Musik]
was war das
was ist das für ein ding
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das
mein gott ich hab' hab' ich will auf
zählen sagt ich kann nicht schnell
laufen was ist das was soll das warum
sind die plötzlich auch neue tiere und
ich weiß gar nicht genau wo ich
langlaufen oder wo ich überhaupt hin
will ich will einfach nur an irgendeinen
ort wo ich irgendwie so ein bisschen
sicherheit habe weil irgendwie ist hier
alles nur stockfinster ich sehe nichts
und ich ich ich weiß auch nicht was das
für monster sind ich hab mein buch nicht
mit dabei ich glaube es wird wirklich
erst mal ganz kurz am meisten sinn
machen wenn ich dieses buch erst mal
ganz kurz holen würde hier vorne haben
wir dieses komische noch lässt ding und
wir haben dieses komische skelettteile
was mich auch vorhin direkt angegriffen
hat deswegen jetzt erstmal ganz fix
überlaufen bringt allerdings ist es dann
links ist es heute ich hab's gesehen ich
habe es gesehen kommt mir entgegen es
ist es ist nicht mehr nach
oh mein gott
wo habe ich mein buch
das ist das wetter beziehungsweise die
hölle war mir sonst schon immer das gut
genug mit den ganzen komischen monstern
die da sind und mit den ganzen sachen
die man nicht angucken darf oder muss
man gold mitnehmen und damit die ich
habe kein gold mitgenommen
ich bin so ein idiot war ich habe
nämlich deswegen auch angegriffen von
daher mache ich mir jetzt mal ganz kurz
hier gold stiefel und ziehe mir meine
eisen stiefel aus vielleicht sind sie
deswegen auch nur böse auf mich gewesen
ich muss jetzt allerdings auch mal ganz
kurz die eben ausschau halten nach
meinem buch das habe ich nämlich wollen
ihr nicht gefunden ich bin eigentlich
ist durchgegangen hier ist es auf jeden
fall irgendwo drin hier ist es auch
nicht drin hier ist es nicht hier ist es
nicht und hier ist es ebenfalls nicht
dann muss es ja eigentlich in der
anderen kissel händen sein die sonne
geht auch schon wieder unter und leute
ich muss wirklich wissen was das für
komische monster sind ich muss wissen
womit nichts zu tun habe hier
ist mein buch auch nicht drin
wo ist das zwei stunden später ich habe
mal gegoogelt und man kann sich dieses
buch wenn man es verloren haben sollte
und wieder zurück holen dafür benötigt
man allerdings ein ganz normales buch
was ich habe man benötigt irgendeiner
irgendein item von dieser modifikation
wie beispielsweise ich habe er leicht
hinten beute die kann ich auf jeden fall
nehmen allerdings braucht man auch noch
grünen farbstoff und ich habe keinen
grünen farbstoff den kriegt man nur von
kakteen und ich habe auch keine kakteen
deswegen müssen wir es jetzt leider
tatsächlich ohne buch hier schaffen und
wir befinden uns auch wieder zurück in
der
wir sind zurück in der hölle
wir müssen irgendwie gucken
dass wir es hinkriegen
was ist das was ist das
was ist das
was will der von mir der kommt die ganze
zeit an das ist in so einem skelett
irgend so ein skelett fisch
alter und er macht auch nicht wenig
schaden
[Musik]
das kann doch nicht sein dass sie mich
die ganze attackieren woher kommen die
denn
[Musik]
hey
also beschissener
hättest du in der hölle wirklich nichts
bauen können ich freue mich jetzt
einfach mal an der seite hoch und lauf
hier ein bisschen langen zu gucken was
es hier so alles gibt ich orientiere
mich die ganze zeit noch nach quartz
aufgrund vom einfach mit luca staffel 1
sowie eine menge quatsch benötigt haben
allerdings brauchen wir das ja
eigentlich gar nicht mehr die sache ist
dass ich das allerdings trotzdem
mitnehmen werde weil man ja auch gut
handeln kann und es zudem auch eine
menge erfahrung gibt beim abbau
[Musik]
was ist das
er greift nicht auch an
ich habe so eine erfahrung bekommen
alter
da unten sind noch mehr von dem was
ist hier los was soll das
was war was wollt ihr alle von mir was
soll das machen sie so viele neue
monster ich will raus hier guck mal die
da unten fliegen auch die ganze drum wo
ist der ist hier oben passt er ist dass
ich brauche dieses buch zurück ich muss
kakteen finden in der nächsten folge
damit ich mir dieses buch wieder kräftig
an was sollen das wieso kommt diese
ganzen tieren die sowieso töten ich muss
hier weg ich muss sie ganz ganz schnell
weg
hier vorne bin ich hergekommen wir doch
mal ganz schnell wieder den gleichen weg
zurück jetzt hier fordert drauf auf das
buch stein ich hoffe jetzt einfach nur
das von irgendwo jetzt auch so eine
komische schlange oder spinne kommt oder
was auch immer das war der hier vorne
greift mich auch an da dürfte auch auf
mich zu allerdings attackiert mich erst
mal niemand mehr und wir sind
in sicherheit
perfekt
ich habe mich nicht auf diese folge
vorbereitet
ich dachte mir einfach
geil lasst uns in die hölle gehen das
ganze anschauen live mit euch zusammen
aber dass uns da so was erwarten wird
hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht
bitte schreibt mir kommentare was das
für mops waren was das für komische
viele teile waren für komische
skelettteile führt ein komisches loch
ness monster und ob ihr tipp habe wie
ich mir dieses buch vielleicht wieder
zurückholen kann oder ob ihr wisst wo
ich vergessen habe
ansonsten will ich das heute wieder
jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch gefällt
hat das kann einen daumen hoch unter dem
video abonniert main kanal und trägt auf
die glocke wenn die nächste folge
minecraft mit du gar nicht verpassen
wollt schreibt mir gern und in die
kommentare was in der nächsten folge
machen sondern ich muss mich jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen beruhigen
[Musik]